- [Instructor] Times in our
dealings with powers series.
We might wanna take the derivative,
or we might want to integrate them.
And in general, we can
do this term by term.
What do I mean by that?
Well, that means that the derivative of f,
f prime of x, is just
gonna be the derivative
of each of these terms.
So that's gonna be the sum
from n equals one to infinity.
And let's see, the
derivative of x to the n
is n times x to the n minus one.
So I could write this as n
times x to the n minus one
all of that over n.
And these ns will cancel out,
so this is just going to be,
this is just going to
be x to the n minus one.
So this is taking the
derivative with respect to x.
Similarly, we could integrate,
we could integrate and we could evaluate,
we could evaluate the
integral of f of x dx,
and this is going to be
equal to some constant plus,
if we integrate this term by term.
And so this is going
to be equal to the sum
from n equals one to infinity.
And let's see, we increment the exponent,
so x to the n plus one,
and then we divide by that.
So times n plus one times
this n right over here.
So this is a common
technique that you will see
when dealing with power series.
And we're gonna go a little
bit more into the details,
because you can only do this for x values
within the interval of
convergence for the power series.
And as we will see, the
interval of convergence
for these different series
is slightly different.
The intervals are very similar,
but what happens at the
endpoint is different.
So I encourage you, pause this video,
and see if you can figure out
the interval of convergence
for each of these series.
This is the integral
of our original series,
and this is the derivative
of our original series.
So let's start with our original series.
Let's figure out the
interval of convergence.
So we could do that using the ratio test.
So the ratio test, we
would want to do the limit,
the limit as n approaches
infinity of a sub n plus one,
so that's gonna be x to the
n plus one over n plus one,
divided by a sub n, so
that's x to the n over n.
So we want to take the
absolute value of that.
That's gonna be the limit
as n approaches infinity.
Let's see, this is, if
you divide this and this
by x to the n, that's gonna be a one,
and this is just going to be an x,
and then this n is going to end up top.
So this is going to be xn over n plus one.
And this is equal to the limit
as n approaches infinity of,
let's see, if we divide the
numerator and denominators here
by one over,
if we divide by both the numerator
and the denominator by n,
we're gonna get x over
one plus one over n.
And what is this going to be?
Well, this term's gonna go to zero,
so this is just gonna be equal
to the absolute value of x.
And the ratio test tells us
that this series is convergent
if this right over here is less than one,
it's divergent if this
is greater than one,
and it's inconclusive if this equals one.
So we know, let's write that down.
We know we are convergent, convergent,
convergent for
the absolute value of x less
than one when this thing,
when it is less than one.
We know that we are divergent
when this thing is greater than one,
when the absolute value
of x is greater than one.
But what about when the absolute
value of x is equal to one?
That's where the ratio test breaks down
and we have to test that separately.
So let's look at the scenario where
x is equal to one.
When x equals to one,
this series is the sum
from n equals one to infinity
of one to the n over n.
Well, that's just gonna be one over n.
This is the harmonic
series or the p-series
where our p is one.
And we've seen in multiple
videos that this diverges.
So when x equals one, we diverge.
What about when x equals negative one.
When x equals negative one,
this thing becomes the sum
from n equals one to infinity
of negative one to the n over n.
And this is often known as the
alternating harmonic series.
And this one by the
alternating series test,
this one actually converges.
And we've seen that in multiple videos.
So it turns out the
interval of convergence
for our original thing right over here,
our interval of convergence,
interval of convergence,
convergence here,
is we can, x can be,
so it could be, x can be
greater than or equal to negative one,
or I could say negative one
is less than or equal to x,
because if x is negative
one, we still converge,
but then x has to be less than one,
because right at one we diverge,
so we can't say less than or equal to.
So this is the interval of convergence
for our original function.
What about the interval of
convergence for this one
right over here when
we take the derivative?
Well, when we take the derivative,
this is, this is the same
thing as x to the zero
plus x to the first,
plus x to the second,
and we go on and on and on.
Now you might recognize this,
this is a geometric series
with common ratio of x.
Geometric
series,
series, where our common ratio,
often noted by r, is equal to x.
And we know that a
geometric series converges
only in the situation where the,
where our common ratio,
where the absolute value
of our common ratio,
so converges, converges,
only in the situation
where the absolute value
of our common ratio is less than one.
So in this situation, when
we took the derivative
for f prime of x, our
interval of convergence
is almost the same.
So here our interval of convergence
is going to be x has to be between
negative one and one,
but it can't be equal to negative one.
At negative one we would actually diverge,
and at one we would diverge.
So notice, these are almost the same.
If we view these as
series centered at zero,
the radius of convergence is the same.
We can go one above, one
below, one above, one below.
And that's in general truths.
We take derivatives as integrals.
But the endpoints of our interval
of convergence can be different.
And to continue to see this,
I encourage you to use the ratio test
to figure out one, what is the,
well, use the ratio test plus
using the boundary conditions,
figure out what the
interval of convergence is
for the antiderivative,
for the integral here.
And what you will see is
the radius of convergence is the same.
We can go one above
zero and one below zero.
We have to be in that interval.
But as you will see, this one converges
for x equals negative one or x equals one.
I'll just cut to the chase here.
So, interval of, let me
write that in yellow.
The interval of convergence
for this top one converges,
converges for negative one is less than x,
is less than or equal to one.
So notice, they all have the
same radius of convergence,
but the interval of convergence,
it differs at the endpoint.
And if you wanna prove
this one for yourself,
I encourage you to use
a very similar technique
that we use for our original function.
Use the ratio test, you're
gonna come to this conclusion
right over here, and then test the cases
when x is equal to one and
x is equal to negative one.
And you will see when x
is equal to negative one,
you have an alternating p-series,
so that's gonna converge.
And then when x equals one,
you're gonna have a p-series
where the denominator has
a degree larger than one,
or something similar to a p-series.
And you can establish
that it will also converge
in that scenario as well.